we've been here from the beginning of
the creative Katana V2 series with the
original V2 that we reviewed when it
came out to the katana v2x and now the
katana SE is here and I think this
pretty much wraps up the entire V2
series I think I have a katana V2 for my
setup at Home Yonkers one at his desk
upstairs I had the v2x and the SE at my
desk so we are practically drowning in
katanas but that also means we have had
a lot of time with all three iterations
of the V2 series save for the SE which
we'll be talking about today Inside the
Box you get the katana SE the power
cable power cable options wall mount and
of course the remote for the SE speaking
of which here is DSC the first question
would be where's the subwoofer well
you're looking right at it it's built
inside it would be easy to say the SE is
basically just the v2x without the
subwoofer but that's far from the truth
the SE looks like the v2x but the SC is
actually much larger since it has its
core capacity radiate this now creative
swapped out the two 2.5 inch mid-range
speakers and two 0.75 inch tweeters
found in both the V2 and v2x for two
three inch base ones and two 0.75 inch
fabric Dome tweeters and while we're
talking about some of the technical
stuff both the v2x and SC have a peak
power of 180 watts and a total system
power up to 90 Watts RMS the frequency
range for the SE goes from 55 to 20 000
Hertz and the V2 and v2x go from 50 to
20 000 Hertz besides the specifications
and its size you are still essentially
getting the same ish High amid
performance of its siblings or actually
a little bit better but lacking the kick
of a woofer or subwoofer equipped with
its quad passer radiators and now that I
actually think about it it's the perfect
sound bar to compare to the Razer
Leviathan V2 Pro if we had it on hand
but I guessed the Leviathan V2 would do
for now the SE is pretty much everything
the Leviathan video wants to be but
still can't due to its lack of ports and
creative be an audio company the katana
SE sounds a lot better of course
compared to Razer who are a gaming
peripheral company it's very important
to understand that both companies have
different priorities but the conclusion
for this quick comparison is that the
katana SE kicks all kinds of butt quick
note on how the SC looks like the Finish
is actually very similar to that of the
v2x with the V2 having a much darker
brushed Metal finish my only gripe with
how it looks like and I think this goes
for all the katanas actually it's the
material that they use for the screen
right here since the V2 there have been
These Fine Lines that kind of cut
through the microphone segments here and
here and these straight lines definitely
serve some sort of purpose but it's not
really apparent why they are there in
the first place so I do hope that
creative does look into improving the
quality of the glass and you know just
letting us know why those scratches are
there in the first place performance
wise we found that compared to the v2x
with a subwoofer if you want to get the
same volume levels on the se s the v2x
there is is a one to two ratio when the
volume is on 15 for the v2x the SC is on
30. the whole point of the v2x besides
being a more affordable variant to the
V2 was to save space by making the width
of the subwoofer smaller and taller in
the process but also making it less
powerful than the V2 for smaller rooms
that need the quality without the
thunderous power or the V2 it gets
really loud speaking of loud I just want
a shadow creator for sending the katana
SC over to let us check it out and
before we continue this channel is
supported by Prince who help us improve
our content and keep us going so stay
around for the sponsored message if you
looking for a laptop that has both power
and possibility look no further than the
Asus Zenbook 14x OLED it features a
large 70 watt hour battery and stunning
Nano Edge 14.5 inch 2.8k 120hz OLED
display powered by the latest 13th gen
Intel Core I9 CPU and RTX 3050 GPU all
packed in a thin 16.9 mm chassis that
only weighs 1.5 kilograms so you can
stay focused at work or play for more
information check out asus.com the V2 SE
is like the final solution if you don't
have any space for remote for a
subwoofer but you really want a soundbar
for your room this will be exactly what
you're looking for I mean I wouldn't use
this in my living room though you can do
that but I still feel that this will be
perfect for an office room or dormitory
type setup on the katana SC we'll be
playing videos games and music and it
really sounds like the v20 v2x without
the oomph and obviously more emphasis on
the mids and highs same thing goes with
sound staging playing mono effect dude
with just the sound bar like what I do
with the v2x or V2 we were still able to
pick out directional cues footsteps and
react accordingly playing Diablo 4 is
pretty damn immersive from the sounds of
picking up gold to protect out the next
demon you make eye contact with and
combined with the soundtrack man I'm in
love listening to Lavender Hayes by
Taylor Swift while switching between the
v2x at my desk and the SE it's very
clear that the lack of a subwoofer makes
a huge difference in the overall
experience though there's more clarity
now in the highs and mids I'm not saying
that the quad passive radiators are
terrible in any way because there is a
sufficient enough base compared to say
they'll have item B2 but you know I
would still prefer subwoofer but the
real question I need to ask all today is
would you get it at its current price
point at 299 USD while the v2x is at
279.99 USD and the veto is at 329.99 USD
you could literally pay 20 bucks less to
get a subwoofer or pay 30 more for the
V2 where you get the full Katana
experience personally it all boils down
to what you need from the series if you
have the space for woofer and want the
full experience you go with the V2 if
you have the little space for the
subwoofer and need a speaker that won't
weather your neighbors and your bones in
a smaller room or just you know want to
save some cash you get the v2x now if
you don't have any space and move around
a lot and by moving around a lot I mean
if you change your living spaces pretty
often say if you're going from home to
University dorm to staying at a friend's
house for a couple months that kind of
thing and still have some cash to spare
the SE is the way to go if I didn't get
my V2 between the three I would actually
get the v2x because I wouldn't mind
having a bit more leg room under my desk
with a V2 SE coming in second because I
will have even more legroom with all
things considered if you're planning on
getting the katana se you really need to
think about the situation you're
currently in about space and whatnot
cost wise I mean the three of them are
pretty much in the same bracket and it
all comes down to maybe having less
extravagant meals for like what three to
five days which isn't so bad the Katana
SC is still a solid Soundbar with crisp
audio quality without the oomp of their
subwoofers or woofers but it still
sounds like a dream and it leaves a much
smaller footprint in your setup compared
to the other two because it doesn't have
a subwoofer or woofer the next question
would be would you get the SE let me
know in the comments below which of the
three in the katana V2 lineup you'd get
and if you like what we do follow us on
all of our socials right here to keep up
to date with everything we do also maybe
consider hitting the like And subscribe
buttons it goes a long way in helping
the channel out and if you want to see
more stuff check this out
[Music]
thank you
foreign